now our tech savvy kids face so many
challenges in the cyber world one goal
is for us here at 8 news now is try to
help keep them safe here is cyber safe
parent
our cyber safe parents segment looks to
address the multitude of cyber safety
issues that parents and kids now
consistently deal with here are just
some of the issues we covered a kid or
teen sends a questionable or
inappropriate picture to a friend or
partner once they hit send it's too late
if you wouldn't share it with your
grandmother you probably shouldn't share
it with someone else online before it's
down screenshots are taken it's been
shared 20 30 100 times and for a young
person the impact can be devastating
another consistent challenge for our
children cyber bullying where keyboard
classmates are finding courage behind a
screen they're saying things
and spreading things online that nobody
would ever say if they were you know
right in front of another person when
many of us were kids bullying might
happen at school now it can be 24 7.
unfortunately it's it's too consistent
too prevalent you know in today's
society we also dug into the data about
how instagram can be toxic what they're
feeling isn't
supposed to be happening right and it's
happening because
they're on this app instagram was
actually compared to smoking cigarettes
with data showing that it is especially
toxic for teen girls the worst part is
probably how it makes you feel about
yourself sometimes we also visited saint
jude's ranch for children where we found
one path of better and brighter days
ahead for kids who have been the victims
of sex trafficking for kids with complex
trauma kids that have really been you
know truly victimized and abused and
recognizing that child victims of
trafficking need a bit more specialized
services the healing center at st jutes
is the first of its kind program for
this specialized care of child victims a
place of of healing and hope a place of
restoration a place for joy to come back
into young people's lives